- beer whatever I should probably turn
up the lights good it's so cozy
anyway this game it's very similar to
him and which house which may or may I
watch me play or played yourself those
two are super awesome games I would
honestly recommend you to play or watch
me play them before going to this one I
think it honestly is probably the best
free game that I have ever played and I
hope I hope this is half as good as it
then then it'll be totally worth it
I heard a lot of great things about them
I'm looking forward to play it it's
supposed to be a horror in the same
sense pretty much RPG Maker you bros
seem to love it I love it let's do it
northern Germany drivas residence
someone is knocking on the door and it's
gonna assume it's a girl well like I am
so yeah weird fanart incoming father are
you there
what father oh yeah how many times have
I told you not to come down here sorry
father but um I'm too scared to sleep on
my own
oh yeah Joey you're never alone
your mother is always there at your side
she's always looking after you are ya
okay now place get a pad yes Father
good guy father tomorrow's yes
anniversary of her death will visit her
grave together
okay now go back to bed please I'll be
resting - shortly okay so she would she
say stop
Wow no wow help me how set a shake
what what I thought it was a motorbike
yeah I was probably a motorbike Oh
my motorbike I know a father's secret my
father is a scientist he loved research
and is always locked up in the lab in
the basement
I was heard things from that lab animals
and human screaming even at young age I
knew what my father was doing so I
pretended I wasn't looking but I didn't
know or hear anything a feigned
ignorance the whole time
because I loved father that's not the
only secret I know when mom and I
weren't around
he and his helper would make love a fine
sample I shall dispose of the remaining
materials myself that can wait come
Berea doctor
Dicer she's aware of our relationship
hmm what does it matter I don't believe
she's fun of me that is the problem
the girl will be 11 soon as the
Troublesome age to be sure she can't
mine please make sure she's never had
she's my most precious what's going on
here seriously this is a real-time order
back time
whoa whoa did you see that brass uh-huh
what a cute little room it's midnight
today's the day mom went to heaven mom I
can never sleep when I think about mom I
portrait that mom mom nice test I do
love her but she scares me
she always looking at me with those eyes
I hate her but I know father likes her
and father had got married I guess she
would be my new mom I don't want her to
be my mom I don't need a new mom there's
only one mom in the world for me
mom why did you have to go for a little
girl dresser full of clothes why is that
sound it's actually it feels like I'm
discovering something at the love doll a
doll I got from father it's so old and
worn
[Music]
reminds me over to the moon honestly I
brought you a present I yeah yeah it's a
doll thank you Father thank you what a
predator it's almost like it's rare
I gotta feel like it's gonna come alive
and kill me just just saying Oh for
[ __ ] sake uh-huh Wow what is that
something strange fell out what is this
got again gems are hidden in various
places some require doing special events
to get you can see your gamma count on
the menu find them all and trip a lot
all right
snowball the pet rabbit Oh snowball is
not friendly that my trunk the room
feels colder too sudden I'm kind of
scared I should get back to bed all
[Music]
right fine we're going back to bed good
night
well that's a nice night's game so far
[Music]
ah Thank You Lana father would you have
a look at this way
give me a mile bed just putting this hey
it's a lot of dialogue reading yes it's
totally reminding out with me up to the
moon a flower crown does it look good on
me yes I think it suits you well
yay thank you Father we do this on
midsummer every in Sweden every year I'm
sorry I can always play with you I'm
pretty good at making those actually
don't want to brag or anything but you
know it's alright I'm glad I could play
with you today father is that the mom oh
my you two are playing mom like father
made me a flower Kraft say boys are good
at making flower crowns that's wonderful
it's great on you so you played with him
all day yeah
we should do this again father yes we
should next time your mother should join
in
well I look forward to it cuff pack I'm
sorry just another thing don't push
yourself if you're not feeling well
come get some medicine from Marion it
should help you to get better no I can
get that myself
mom are you hurt you're okay right sorry
to worry about giving don't excite
ancient be anxious please higher smile
keeps me going best of all if I can see
you smiling it only makes me worry okay
now let's get back for dinner I made
have a good steak tonight your favorite
I'm alright I love mom's hamburger
I love mom's hamburgers too
aha of course a handbag it's not the
best in the world they don't sound that
good we were so happy then that was
Maria but even so the three of us were a
happy family but then mom passed away
from illness and the happiness we had
then well something tells me she did not
pass away from just illness something
tells me that Maria was involved oh is
that that scream father something
happened I will go check on father all
righty then
I have a bad feeling wha
what's this sound is that a Oh [ __ ] love
whoa what the lock
where's your net balls you don't have
any net boy no don't run egg who said
come this way to somebody that running
I'm running is that me what the [ __ ]
it's me this way that's way stay with me
[Laughter]
many interesting Beckham is going on who
are you now justice aggressive a barely
a Salesman
why the [ __ ] would a salesman enter
little Gaza
okay now you look like an ogre I hope to
know you young lady
but it's quite troublesome to think that
corpses loiter
Cortez this like boxes from sorry my
word masses like that well tentacles but
you saw with copses of your father's
test subjects overcome with anger
the sissies have been brought back to
the power of the curse to take revenge
on your father of course
why is that to a chain his desires he
was killed so many as part of his
examination he must have realized by now
your father's true nature and yet you
wish to save him
treble dark alright so that's a pretty
[ __ ] up so my my perhaps she cannot
yet to understand how Sarah very
interesting so so far at least check a
plane and it's a bit scary father was
all this came to me he's the only father
I had and I promised mom too I really
love this piano music is goddess the red
eyed stranger gave Jack the power to
curse on us the jack said thank you red
eye stranger now I can get my revenge
hey mom
yes I am what's father's always up to
down below it's a very difficult job
you'll understand when you're older I am
I want to be all there its own men
whatever happens you should have hated
your father mom what's the matter of
course I wouldn't hate father I see mom
do you not like father no nothing like
that
I'm just like you I I love you farther
just as much yes you give me a bit
unpredictable
so let's support each other no matter
what promise yeah now back to the story
[Music]
what happened to me in the game mom
whatever happens I love father don't
worry I have to go save father it's not
a pig crow all right so the cross side
of the save files how do I exit all
right here we go I don't know if I trust
this though and that is missing a
section all right we're going in here
oh that's where we came from the weird
guy is missing let's follow the period
how's that what is making that sound
it's very similar to which house in
terms of life
[Music]
okay you can do it there we go don't rip
off epoxy whoa whoa this is totally
taken out of Ed I got another Ken better
it seems like a doll and get the feeling
it's not a doll I don't like this ride
he's here before all right just go
[ __ ] out oh thank god
Wow that's not a good start man it's
locked [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's something now
oh dude wow what a lead you gonna die
woman nice a lot
bloody cry bloody head bedroom archive
key dude and I'm gonna have to end this
episode here I have to say this game
looks like it's gonna be a really really
interesting story so like a favorite if
you enjoyed especially when I do and you
let's place it's really helps out a lot
so I appreciate it
I hope your boys are looking forward to
this as much as I do and stay awesome to
genius power in your future neck
something on the right
[Music]